[Musique]
m
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat l'émission qui vous
plonge au coeur des travaux des
sénatrices et des sénateurs émission
consacrée aux droits des femmes ce matin
au lendemain du 8 mars journée
internationale des droits des femmes
hier à paris soixante mille personnes
ont défilé contre les violences
sexuelles et les inégalités femmes
hommes et ce matin vous allez suivre une
table ronde sur la place des femmes dans
les médias audiovisuels sont elles assez
présentes ont elles autant la parole que
les hommes sur les plateaux quelles
nouvelles mesures de parité faut-il
inscrire dans la loi
toutes les réponses dans cette audition
bonjour donc je vais vous parler de
l'étude qu'on a réalisé li na pour
introduire à mon propos je vais je vais
la situer par rapport aux autres études
quantitatives qui a pu avoir par le
passé donc dans les études quantitatives
connu qu'on a à ma connaissance il ya le
rapport annuel du csa qui publie une
sorte de baromètre depuis 2015 sur la
représentation des femmes et des hommes
dans les programmes donc eux y se base
sur les taux de présence c'est à dire
ont l'art déclare le nombre de personnes
le nombre d'hommes le nombre de femmes
par types d'intervenants et donc balle
il ya énormément de programmes là cette
année par exemple il y avait cinquante
mille heures de programmes
une seule environ 50000 programme
déclaré la limite de cette métrique
c'est que le
si on compte les gens ça dit pas à quel
point il parle non il ya le global media
monitoring project
c'est un exercice international qui a
lieu tous les cinq ans l'appareil il
compte les personnes par et il est
classé disent les experts les politiques
etc
mais c'est un jour tous les cinq ans
l'avantagé c'est dansant la dernière
fois c'était dans 114 pays donc c'est
très dur de généraliser à partir d'une
empreinte d'une journée tous les cinq
ans il ya le rapport de michel riser et
brigitte grésy de 2008 où il ya une
partie quand here i ll s'était basé sur
six chaînes télé station radio la limite
au site cette approche pour la partie
qu'en tire c'est qu'elle nous avait pris
les jt principalement aider certaines
autres émissions chaque chaîne pour
chaque chaîne ça passe et il y avait
analysé de six minutes 6 minutes c'était
le 6 minutes de m6 à 3h une seule
journée aussi donc dressé un constat du
paysage audiovisuel en se fondant sur
six minutes pour une chaîne sert c'est
limité mais ça à hull mairie ç'a eu le
mérite d'exister
de toute façon il n'y a pas de grand
chose d'autre
et donc elle avait utilisé trois
métriques taux de présence comme le csa
taux d'expression c'est le temps de
parole donc c'est ce dont je vais vous
parler après donc le taux d'expression
c'est beaucoup plus long à mesurer
manuellement
donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'il ya une si
petite quantité et le taux
d'identification c'était le nombre de
références orale à des personnalités
hommes ou femmes savoir de ti parle les
gens sinon il ya une autre étude en 2014
du csa belge il avait analysé environ
trente six heures pendant une semaine en
comptant le temps de pâques le temps de
parole donc là le grand débat faut-il
faire les choses à la main ou
automatiquement les deux mon général
donc dans le cas des des approches
manuel c'est coûteux et quand c'est trop
coûteux
à la fin les gens le font pas ce que ça
vaut trop chers et souvent le temps d'
analyse est très supérieur au temps de
visionnage des documents par contre les
humains
sont plus intelligents que les machines
pour le moment et heureusement dont ils
peuvent pas décrire des choses beaucoup
plus complexe que peut le faire en une
machine il ya une partie de subjectivité
un site y est pas et les limites de
beaucoup d' approche manuel c'est le peu
le faible nombre d'exemples donc
généraliser à partir de peu d'exemples
ça pose problème dans le cas des
approches automatique
on peut détecter des phénomènes simple
faire la différence tout une voix
d'homme une voix de femme c'est quelque
chose d'à peu près simple ça permet de
se permettre d'analyser 100 % de ce qui
est diffusé à l'antenne
ça permet d'alimenter le débat citoyen
pareil en parlant avec des responsables
de l'audiovisuel des fois ils nous
disent on est nos dirigeants ils
gouvernent parler chiffres si on leur
donne pas de chiffres bah ils prennent
pas de décisions
donc ça permet justement d'en donner
même même cédé chiffre limité se permet
en temps réel ça permet aussi
d'interagir avec les approches manuel et
on en reparlera plus tard donc ce qu'on
fait à li na
alors on détecte les voix d'hommes et de
femmes donc là c'est la modalité audio
ça le mérite de marcher sur la radio et
la télé c'est assez rapide à calculer
les machines calcul ça il faut une
minute et une machine pour analyser une
heure le verrou c'est les
la différence entre une voix d'homme une
voix de femme c'est quelque chose en
partie construit socialement donc tous
les gens qui s'écartent des normes des
standards bah ça marche moins bien mais
ça marche moins bien mais des humains se
se tromperait aussi un il n'y a pas que
les machines qui se comprennent donc on
fait aussi on analyse les visages
justement pour comparer le temps la
visibilité l'audibilité donc la cds ça
demande un peu plus de temps de calcul
et pour l'instant ce qu'on arrive à
faire c'est juste détecter les visages
de face et on essaie de faire des choses
un peu plus intelligente de quoi les
gens parlent certains appelleront ça du
kali moi j'appelle ça plutôt du cantique
partir du moment où ces chiffres air
donc l'idée pour l'instant on assez
assez prospectifs parce que c'est plus
dur donc pour l'instant on a fait des
premiers prototypes de taux
d'identification
enfin je vous montrera sa rapidement là
la difficulté d d analyse du contenu du
discours c'est que les système de
transcription de la parole c'est des
technologies moins mature et donc ça
fait beaucoup d'erreurs surtout pour les
noms propres les noms de lieux tous les
maux peu courant en fait est qu'ils sont
très intéressants pour décrire les
nouvelles donc sur l'analyse au gharb ce
qu'on peut faire là vous avez un exemple
on peut analyser une journée entière la
semence pouvoir on voit que de minuit à
2h du matin il y avait beaucoup d'hommes
sur m6 de 2 heures du matin à 7 heures
il y avait très peu d'hommes et très peu
de femmes se passer la nuit
ça devait être une programmation
musicale et ensuite ça variés dans la
journée donc on peut analyser comme ça
par tranche horaire
manière exhaustive dans le cas des
visages bon là je vous ai montré un
exemple un peu un peu dur sur les
limites de ce qu'on peut faire on peut
détecter les visages après faire la
différence entre avoir un visage un
visage sur un poster visage dans un
cadre pour l'instant c'est pour
l'instant ça marche pas très bien et
mais bon voilà juste pour vous donner
une idée de ce qu'on mesure on mesure
tout ça quand on mesure des visages donc
le corpus d'étude sur l'étude du temps
de parole c'était c'était sept cent
mille heures à la rouge parle il ya
plutôt un million d'heures qui ont été
traités avec plusieurs chaînes de 10h à
minuit à l'épaule ça représentait 30 ans
de visionnage pour la télé et 50,50
visionnage pour la radio ça ça a été
traité en il fallait un an et demi de
calcul on an et demi de calcul
il suffit d'avoir plusieurs machines ça
peut très vite si on a dit machine s'est
réduit en moins que à peu près donc les
gros constats c'étaient les hommes
parlent deux fois plus que les femmes à
à la télé et à la radio
il parle encore plus à la radio mais
c'est à peu près équivalent ce qu'on
avait vu on avait comparé pour les
différentes chaînes
les femmes parlent davantage les chaînes
avec des étoiles c'est les chaînes cible
un public féminin chéri 25 t va donc sur
toutes les chaînes on n'en a pas vu une
seule où la parole des femmes était
supérieure à celle des hommes
elle était précieux dial sur les chaînes
à destination d'un public féminin très
très faible sur les chaînes de sport un
peu plus faible sur les chaînes culture
notamment art et c'est là ce qui était
très amusant c'était de voir qu'en
faisant cette approche massive on
retombait sur les mêmes constats que le
rapport de
michel riser et brigitte grésy qui a été
basé sur quelques heures donc prend 1
million d'heures ou ou trois finales on
a un certain nombre de conclusions
similaires mais c'est bien peu souvent
en recherche
ce qui est intéressant c'est de
conforter des hypothèses donc dix
personnes qui disent la même chose c'est
plus forte une seule personne qui le dit
donc on a vu aussi c'est que le
pourcentage de parole des femmes à la
radio a évolué de 1 tiare environ 1 35%
donc c'est un phénomène qui bouge on a
également analysé les différences
faibles et fortes audiences
donc ce qu'on a vu par exemple c'est sur
les chaînes de télé chaîne de télé
publique ya pas de différence majeure
entre faibles et fortes audiences chaîne
de télé privée y a huit points de
différence à nom pareil la limite de
cette méthodologie c'est yes une heure
de forte audience est ce que c'est la
même pour toutes les chaînes ce qu'on a
pu voir c'est sur les chaînes de radio
celle qui cible les à dos plutôt le soir
les chaînes pour adultes c'est plutôt le
matin donc là on
on a fixé les heures de forte audience
on voudrait être plus rigoureux il
faudra une heure de forte audience
relative à chaque chaîne ça marche voilà
donc leur suite on a comparé on a
comparé le temps d'exposition visuel
autant de au temps de parole pour six
chaînes dont classé des résultats qui
sont pas dans l'étude des plus récents
donc ce qu'on a vu c'est que pour pour
toutes les chaînes le temps de le temps
d'exposition visuel on voit plus les
femmes qu'on ne les entend sur toutes
les chaînes
c'est moins vrai pour arte et france 3
mais pour toutes les autres chaînes il
ya des grosses différences près on s'est
amusé aussi à comparer la manière dont
parle des hommes et des femmes en
fonction des chaînes donc tf1 utilise
beaucoup c'est la chaîne qui utilisent
le plus le terme mademoiselle tu es plus
à l'état civil
tiana le plus utilisent moins fait ses
variantes la femme avec un grand f
c'est plutôt sur artères et les filles
c'est sur m6
je vous rassure en fait le même constat
est fait pour les hommes en fait les
mettre c'est sur canal+ les hommes c'est
sur arte avec un grand h et les garçons
sur m6 aussi donc là dans la continuité
de ça on a
on est désormais financé par l'agencé
nationale de la recherche sur un
programme de recherche qui correspond à
300 moi personne qui va durer trois ans
et demi et sept partenaires in à 10h de
laboratoire d'informatique le yom le
leem 6 3 laboratoires de sciences
humaines
un comité d'experts dont le csa donc le
but c'est d'aller plus loin faire des
choses trouvées typiquement trouver le
bon compromis entre ce que les machines
peuvent faire il ya du sens pour décrire
la complexité de la présence des hommes
et des femmes dans les médias
les travaux en cours on a participé au
rapport annuel du csa qui sort le 5 mars
donc on a analysé le temps de parole en
complément des taux de présence on à
aider à détecter les fausses
déclarations ou les erreurs de
déclaration et on à le comparer ces deux
choses on a une étude qui va sortir sur
les réalisatrices dans les programmes de
fiction donc là dessus on a compté
l'impact du sexe sur le temps de parole
et on va participer au global media
monitoring project dans quelques jours
voilà si pour aller plus loin les des
liens vers les derniers outils
je tiens à préciser qu'on fait de l'open
source tous nos logiciels sur l'open
source et que les données congénères
sont souvent diffusés en open data sur
datta le goût bonjour madame la
présidente mesdames les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs j'ai consacré en
effet ma carrière à la télévision et à
la fiction en particulier très
rapidement j'ai créé 2,2 société de
production était pdg de mes sociétés
alliées reproduction et barjac
production j'ai été dès 5 ans directrice
de la fiction de france 2 entre 2000 et
2005 et depuis je suis directrice
générale donc de barjac et directrice
générale du groupe telfrance
j'ai donc passé même ma vie avec la
fiction si l'expérience forge la
conscience c'est forte de mes nombreuses
années dans ce milieu que j'ai acquis la
conviction que sans mesures coercitives
hélas laden ne changera pas on part
vraiment de trop trop loin il suffit de
regarder pour s'en convaincre
dans d'autres secteurs comme la
politique les entreprises privées où la
parité tant qu'elle était souhaitable et
malgré des sanctions financières n'était
pas effective il a fallu passer par des
quotas pour infléchir ces inégalités
par ailleurs l'expérience dans d'autres
pays nous encourage dans cette voie je
pense nous pensons ap fdm que les choses
doivent changer de façon peut-être un
peu radicale avec des quotas temporaires
sur cinq ans par exemple avec un premier
palier à 30% de femmes réalisatrices
elles sont aujourd'hui en moyenne 12 à
15% de femmes à réaliser des fictions
diffusées à la télévision
pire encore on n'observe aucune
évolution probante depuis dix ans ce qui
nous conforte dans l'idée que les choses
ne peuvent malheureusement pas changer
d'elles-mêmes les habitus ont créé les
réflexes les garçons là on peut pas
compter que sur la bonne volonté
au jour d'aujourd'hui les deux tiers des
sociétés de production ayant produit au
moins un épisode de fiction en 2018
n'ont pas fait appel à des réalisatrices
88% des auteurs réalisateurs d'oeuvres
inédites sont des hommes sont les
chiffres
selon les chiffes c'est ça est ce assez
dès 2018 en novembre 2019 le cnc a sorti
une étude sur la diffusion à la
télévision des oeuvres
cinématographiques réalisées par des
femmes
on retient que en 2018 les films
réalisés par des femmes représentent 8%
de l'ensemble des diffusions de films
des chaînes historiques
l'argument classique pour contrer les
copains c'est de nous dire que cela va
empêcher la créativité entraver la bonne
marche artistique
nous pensons au contraire car une des
conséquences de l'uniformisation
masculine des regards c'est aussi une
fille née des oeuvres avec un point de
vue exclusivement masculin il y à une
lecture au féminin pour rendre compte de
la diversité des sujets de la façon de
les appréhender qui est de fait
confisquer côté diffusion en
avant-soirée 23% des épisodes de
fictions audiovisuelles inédits sont
réalisées par deux femmes
c'est l'effet feuilleton des trois
feuilleton quotidien que nous avons
depuis deux ans en france mais la
présence des femmes pour l art elysées
des séries de 52 minutes qui est le
format dominant reste très faible moins
de 10% des épisodes diffusés quant à
l'argument on ne trouve pas de femme
réalisatrice on peut répondre si mais
vous ne les voyez pas elles sont là moi
même dans mon activité de productrice il
m'a fallu me battre pour faire émerger
des talents féminins et des
réalisatrices
elles sont aussi nombreuses à l'entrée
qu'à la sortie de la féministe mais 80%
d'entre elles deviennent script ou
monteuse j'ai fait très rapidement une
estimation sur les fictions en
production en 2019 et 2020 en france sur
42 téléfilm unitaire s'ils sont réalisés
par des femmes sur 87 épisodes de séries
12 sont réalisés par des femmes
on a encore beaucoup à faire mais la
question ne se résume pas la seule
présence des femmes réalisatrices nous
demandons que des études affiné soient
produites pour élargir le champ d'action
au monteuse au directrice photo
directrice de production chef d co
productrice et directrice artistique
les principaux chefs de poste à ce jour
aucune étude n'est capable de nous
donner une vision d'ensemble
bientôt va s'ouvrir à l'assemblée
nationale le débat sur la réforme de
l'audiovisuel et comme le hce nous
pensons qu'il faut l'inscrire dans la
loi d orientation pour atteindre
l'égalité réelle
nous sommes favorables dans l'adieu
visuels en particulier à ce qu'une
disposition oblige par exemple à
renseigner pour chacun des postes clés
s'il s'agit d'un homme ou d'une femme
est d'inscrire la parité comme une
condition d'obtention d'une partie des
aides publiques
nous sommes dans un temps de réductions
budgétaires drastiques
et je ne sais pas si les bonus seront
envisageables
par ailleurs nous serions favorables la
création d'un indice permettant
d'évaluer les bonnes pratiques des
sociétés de production quelle qu'elle
soit quelle que soit leur taille
dès lors quels buts b qu'elle bénéficie
dette publique
il s'agirait d' une moyenne globale sur
leur production annuelle dans un premier
temps peut-être nous devons avoir la
même attention à compter les femmes
devant et derrière la caméra il s'agit
bien sûr d'être réaliste et pragmatique
et savoir composer avec les contraintes
de notre secteur en matière de quotas je
profite de cette audition pour remercier
l'ina
avec qui nous sortons dans quelques
jours une étude inédite réalisée sur 10
ans diffusion de fiction à la télévision
et cette étude constitue pour nous une
première étape de la question des femmes
dans la fiction nous la dévoileront
conjointement au csa le 5 mars et je
termine en vous disant que cette étude
doit nous qu'on nous conforte dans la
nécessité de créer un observatoire dont
a parlé bouchra dédié pour appréhender
avec précision l'état de la situation et
mettre en musique nos engagements lors
de la conférence pékin plus bas merci
donc je vais passer la parole maintenant
à madame marie anne bernard qui est
directrice de la démarche rse de france
télévisions à vous madame merci madame
la présidente
mesdames les sénatrices je vais essayer
d'être bref sur le petit compte rendu
que je vais vous faire sur nos
engagements à france télévision parce
que je pense
il ya évidemment un certain nombre de
questions qui nous sont directement
adressés
nous les les diffuseurs et je pense que
c'est la même chose pour mais pour mes
voisins madame morin desailly a rappelé
tout à l'heure dans ses propos
liminaires que ça faisait quelques
années que le service public se
préoccupait de cette question de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est vrai nous avons vraiment pris le
sujet à bras le corps si je puis dire en
2013 en fait est évidemment l'arrivée en
2015 de delphine ernotte à notre à notre
tête à renforcer cette cet engagement
comment nous avons procédé bain en
essayant de mettre en place une
méthodologie de commencer par des états
des lieux d'avoir un petit nombre de
démarches pour pouvoir poser des
objectifs est évidemment à près de nous
donner les outils d'évaluation de ce que
nous avons mis en place
christine kelly parlé du rôle du du csa
c'est peut-être pas tout à fait
habituelle de la part des diffuseurs
mais effectivement le rôle du cs en la
matière a été absolument capital en
particulier avec la délibération de 2015
qui nous a permis à nous diffuseur
justement de
poser cette méthodologie très précise et
de pouvoir tous les ans avoir des
résultats donc pouvoir évaluer les
démarches et donc à partir de là de nous
fixer démarche de démarche de
progression
la question de la place des femmes à
france télévisions c'est évidemment
d'abord la question de leur place à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise
oui aujourd'hui nous avons une
présidente comme radio france à arte à
france médias monde
le premier geste de la présidente ça a
été de nommer un comité exécutif
paritaire ce qui est effectivement
change considérablement la physionomie
d'un groupe et après cela permet de
descendre dans les autres niveaux de
direction des chiffres très rapide
aujourd'hui
en global 41 45 % pardon des salariés de
france télévisions sont des femmes sur
la catégorie des journalistes pour les à
nous en sommes à peu près 40%
aujourd'hui les comités de direction
sont composés de 45% de femmes
les cadres supérieurs et dirigeants sont
pour 40% des femmes donc les chiffres en
interne ont effectivement beaucoup bougé
ça fait quelques années que je suis dans
cette maison et nous n'étions pas du
tout à ces niveaux de chiffres il ya une
il ya une dizaine d'années mais on ouvre
un chantier et je crois qu'il est
collectif et que vous allez probablement
l'ouvrir aussi dans vos travaux sur la
question de l'espace numérique puisque
effectivement le le développement
numérique de france inquiets de france 5
de france télévisions est est en marche
et c'est vrai qu'il ya un réel problème
de la représentation des femmes dans ce
monde-là de ce nouveau monde du
numérique et il faut que nous en france
télévisions nous soyons extrêmement
vigilants sur 7 sur cette question là
alors évidemment la place des femmes à
france télévisions c'est aussi et bien
sûr leur place
leur place à l'antenne alors comme tous
les diffuseurs nous remplissons tous les
ans les tableaux du csa qui donc nous
permet de comptabiliser le nombre des
femmes animatrices journaliste
chroniqueuse invité invité politique et
en particulier la catégorie des expertes
que nous comptons nous toute l'année
mais je crois que les autres diffuseurs
aussi maintenant toute l'année sur un
certain nombre d'émissions qui sont
choisies en accord avec le csa et dans
lesquels évidemment circulent des
experts et des des experts sur
l'ensemble de la représentation sur nos
antennes christine kelly il disait
aujourd'hui il y à des secteurs nous
avons une majorité de femmes
et c'est assez vrai dans la présentation
de nos journaux télévisés
si vous regardez un peu france 2 et
france 3 le journal de 13h le journal de
20 heures depuis deux ans et sap a été
rien comme symbole que l'arrivée d'anne
sophie lapix à la tête de ce qui est
encore la grand-messe de l'information
du 20 heures
c'est vrai aussi pour les rendez vous
d'information de france 3 le midi comme
le 19/20 le soir et un des soucis à la
création de la chaîne
franceinfo le canal 27 avec nos amis de
radio france de l'ina et france médias
monde ça a été aussi à l'antenne sur le
canal 27 d'avoir une présentation des
séquences de journaux paritaire des le
dès le début ce qui est important pour
nous c'est vous l'avez dit madame la
rapporteure c'est de voir dans quel
domaine
nos femmes journalistes se exerce alors
évidemment la présentation d'un jt comme
le 20h c'est déjà symboliquement
important moi j'ai vu un autre un autre
symbole intéressant l'année dernière
c'est quand françois lenglet qui portait
la parole économique de 2 de france 2
depuis un certain nombre d'années a été
remplacée par une journaliste économique
qui s'appelle alexandra bensaïd et qui
est désormais le visage de l'économie de
france 2 même chose pour l'émission
politique de référence de france 2
l'émission politique lui qu'il entend
présenter quelques années présenté par
david pujadas
puis en duo avec léa salamé et au départ
de david pujadas et léa salamé qui a
pris les rênes de l'émission politique
est là à côté d'elle thomas sotto mais
puisque vous parliez madame 2 duo tout à
l'heure le rapport dans le duo à la
présentation de l'émission politique 7
aujourd'hui inversés c'est à dire que
c'est léa salamé qui est la pilote de
l'émission
j'ai parlé à l'instant de la catégorie
importante des expertes oui c'est pour
nous un indicateur fondamental parce
qu'il dit la transmission du savoir et
il dit le recours à la compétence et le
recours aux savoirs c'est pour ça qu'il
depuis sept ans maintenant on a commencé
en 2013 avec d'ailleurs le concours de
brigitte grésy que vous citiez qu'il
travaillait avec nous sur 7 sur cette
question là et c'est en 2013 que nous
avons inscrit le premier avenant au
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens qui
fixait le premier objectif pour les
femmes expertes qui à l'époque pour 2015
avait été fixé à 30%
laurence bachman a cité à propos des
réalisatrices le premier seuil de 30%
c'est effectivement un seuil important
le choix c'est à partir des 30% que ça
devient vraiment significatif fin qu'on
voit vraiment le l'arrivée des femmes
lorsque delphine r non je tiens à
préciser que nous y sommes arrivés aux
30% à la fin de l'année 2015
et lorsque delphine ernotte est arrivée
elle a fixé un nouvel objectif pour les
cinq ans à venir et qui était très
simplement d'arriver à la parité pour
les experts c'est à dire 50 50
je ne vous cache pas que c'est un
objectif très ambitieux petit à petit on
essaie d'y arriver
j'ai pas encore les chiffres définitifs
puisque c'est le le csa qui valide
effectivement tous ces chiffres et comme
vous l'avez rappelé en les aura la
semaine prochaine en 2018 nous étions
effectivement à 42% d'experte on va être
je pense au même niveau cette année ce
qui veut dire quand même que nous
n'avons pas progressé en un an et ce que
delphine ernotte n'a pas manqué de nous
faire remarquer lorsqu'elle a eu les
premiers les premières estimations
il est probable que les derniers
kilomètres sont les plus difficiles à
franchir
mais pour l'année en cours l'objectif
des 50 50 et toujours et toujours fixé
et on va essayer de on va essayer d'y
d'y arriver
je profite pour dire aléas que oui nous
avons été les premiers partenaires avec
radio france du guide des expertes
avant même sa version numérique nous
étions les partenaires de sa version
papier qui avait été lancé par marie
françoise colombani
on l'a beaucoup porter avec avec radio
france est un outil qui est tout à fait
utile qui a eu en plus la vertu de
pointer le fait que oui il y avait des
femmes expertes à peu près dans tous les
domaines et que l'argument d'un certain
nombre de nos rédacteurs qui était de
nous dire ah bah non sur la défense sur
les relations internationales nous
n'avons pas d'experts et fo les
problèmes budgétaires sont
malheureusement une réalité dans le
service public aujourd'hui n'est pas dit
que le fait que nous ayons fini de
financer le guide soit soit définitif
mais ce qui s'est passé qui est plutôt
bon signe c'est que nos rédactions en
interne et les maisons de production
avec lequel nous travaillons
je pense par exemple à la maison de
production qui produit c dans l'air qui
est de l'émission d' expertise par
excellence qui est souvent souvent cités
sur france 5 ont intégré en fait
maintenant sept dimensions de la
recherche d'experts te et ils ont
constitués chacun leur propre leurs
propres catalogues catalogue d'experts
voilà pour les expertes le deuxième
volet je vais aller très vite de notre
de notre démarche c'est aussi vous ne
l'avez cité la question des stéréotypes
évidemment à partir du moment où nous
créons des images nous créons de la
représentation et nous créons des
stéréotypes et réfléchir à ce que nous
donnons à voir du masculin et du féminin
a été un axe de réflexion très fort là
aussi que l'on mène depuis depuis sept
ans maintenant et en particulier et dès
le début sur la question des programmes
pour enfants et sur la question de
l'animation parce que tous parlent de là
tout part de là le les stéréotypes que
nous faisons circuler sans même nous en
rendre compte d'ailleurs si on se
rendrait compte ce n'était plus de ce ne
serait plus des stéréotypes donc le
premier travail il a été fait avec les
producteurs d'animation sur cette
question qu'est ce qu'on dit du féminin
et du masculin dans les dessins animés
et en particulier pour les plus petits
j'ai toujours eu un exemple favori je
crois que toutes les personnes qui ont
eu des enfants ici connaissent petit
ours brun qui est quand même un
classique de la littérature pour les
enfants et un classique de l'animation
de petit ours brun c'est un best seller
pour les pour les tout petits si vous
vous rappelez il ya 15 ans petit ours il
fait des bêtises il est très mignon
il a un papa qui est assis dans son
fauteuil qui lit le journal qui fume la
pipe est une maman qui est avec un
tablier une cuillère en bois à la main
qui est de toute évidence debout en
train de faire la cuisine
voilà et ça ça a alimenté l'imaginaire
de x générations de petits aujourd'hui
petit ours brun existe toujours mais
papa n'est plus dans son fauteuil
il est occupé à des travaux ménagers ça
peut arriver
maman elle visiblement à des activités
extérieures et surtout petit ours brun
une cousine qui est une héroïne
extrêmement positif et très très très
active
c'est c'est drôle mais en même temps ça
dit des choses très sérieuses sur les
modèles que nous donnons aux enfants
évidemment ce travail sur les
stéréotypes ont la mener laurence
bachman le sait mieux que personne
sur les sur les fictions essayant de
faire évoluer évidemment les les
héroïnes que nous que nous monterons sur
nos antennes je vais pas vous faire le
catalogue mais je pense qu'il est assez
évident que les personnages féminins
dans les séries depuis une dizaine
d'années ont considérablement évolué et
en particulier dans leur rapport au
travail le rapport à la vie sociale le
rapport entre la vie privée et la vie
professionnelle
tout ça a été considérablement
travailler et on arrive à des
personnages pour le moins non
stéréotypée comme captain marleau que
vous voyez peut-être en ce moment les
antennes de france 3 qui effectivement
assez loin de la représentation
classique de la mère au foyer il ya
quelques années
voilà sur les questions que place des
femmes dans les médias nous pose
vous avez probablement entendu avant la
fin de l'année dernière l'engagement
qu'a pris notre présidente delphine
ernotte quincy d'effectivement analyser
et de faire des propositions concrètes
sur la question des réalisatrices
c'est une question c'est une question
majeure en ce moment les unités de
l'unité fiction de france télévisions
est en train de faire un rapport
extrêmement détaillées sur ce qui a été
dans l'ensemble des fictions du groupe
le nombre de réalisatrice qui ont tourné
sur l'année 2019 pour avoir comme pour
les expertes un réel état des lieux
c'est à partir de ce moment là qu elle
définira quels sont les objectifs les
objectifs que nous fixerons mais elle
rejoint elle rejoint le plus de femmes
dans les médias sur l'engagement de
d'objectifs chiffrés et progressif sur
la question des des réalisatrices
j'aurai beaucoup d'autres choses à vous
dire je m'arrête là mais évidemment je
suis à votre disposition pour les
questions merci et bien écoutez déjà
vous avez informé pour petit ours brun
donc forcément que ça faisait très
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas entendu
parler petit ours brun
je vais donner très rapidement la parole
à monsieur bruno laforestrie qui est
président du comité diversité et égalité
de radio france et directeur de la radio
move et donc ensuite ce sera vous madame
puisque je sais que un certain nombre
d'intervenants sont des contraintes
horaires donc merci a à nouveau de
respecter votre temps de parole à vous
monsieur merci madame la présidente
madame la sénatrice donc un quatrième
domine également responsable des
relations extérieures institutionnel de
radio france nous il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont déjà été dit et c'est
vrai donc les éléments évidemment
quantitatif que je vais vous livrer et
même des résultats sur 2010 9 en quasi
exclusivité sur les éléments de ce qu'on
a pu constater sur nos antennes mais
j'en profite justement pour dans ces
conditions faire un point sur
l'entreprise et les entreprises de
médias du fait que notre mission et
d'émettre des contenus et que savoir le
doubs c'est amy et par qui est un
élément important et le contexte de
l'entreprise aujourd'hui radio france
vous avez précisé
et évidemment est une entreprise son
comité exécutif est à majorité féminine
en 1 56 % de femmes
est ce qu'on souhaite souligner ici
c'est que cet homme ce n'est pas un
élément uniquement concernant le comité
exécutif de l'entreprise mais une
volonté qui a été mis en place dès 2016
en créant ce comité égalité diversité
qui représente à la fois toutes les
antennes mais également toutes les
fonctions et notamment à rh de radio
france d'avoir une emprise complète sur
ce sujet au sein d'une entreprise qui
qui comptabilise plus de 4500 salariés
et au moins l'équivalent de 4000 à 5000
personnes qui sont des intermittents et
artistes et évidemment y musiciens vous
comme vous savez donc c'est une c'est
une entreprise qui est importante en
termes d'effectifs et le sujet de
l'égalité de la représentation des
femmes la lutte contre les
discriminations est un sujet aujourd'hui
essentiel et quand 6000 veille m'a
proposé de prendre cette présidence à la
suite de deux femmes qui était
directrice d'antenne de films notamment
bérénice travail chez anne sérode le
propos qu'ont ils ont échangé c'était
une pâte est exemplaire était
avant-gardiste et je pense que l'enjeu
notamment pour les entreprises publiques
de médias dans le contexte de la loi
notamment
c'est justement de poser des actes très
fort aussi bien dans leur gestion
interne que dans leur représentation et
dont leurs fonctions d'émetteurs
évidemment en tant que média et je
soulignerai les fonction managériale
évidemment à la tête de radio france
dans toutes les fonctions qu'elle soit
de gestion de communication mais pas
uniquement mais aussi des fonctions
éditoriales puissante quand vous savez
que des directrice d'antenne sandrine
treiner laurence bloch à la tête de
radio aujourd'hui qui sont importantes
et pour france inter évidemment la
première radio de france
ce qu'il faut quand même souligner et
dans son importance et comme laurence
bloch la plus dire à plusieurs reprises
l'acte puissant qui a été porté de
féminisation de l'antenne depuis quatre
ans est un des éléments extrêmement
rationnelle de succès des nos antennes
dans le sens où le gain d'auditeurs est
un gain d'auditrice aussi et le fait que
des femmes
excellent dans leur fonction est très
bien représenté dans toutes les horaires
dans toutes les stations évidemment fait
en sorte qu'on fédérant public plus
grand et c'est quand même une de nos
missions notamment de service public sur
la question évidemment le
le interne aussi je souligne je pense
que c'est un apport je pense aussi dans
votre réflexion
c'est que notre analyse est que il est
essentiel de que l'entreprise de médias
mais pas uniquement mais on parle des
médias aujourd'hui crée les conditions
d'un développement d'un accompagnement
professionnel et on s'est rendu compte
nous à radio france
évidemment depuis quelques années que ça
va être un énorme sujet qui n'avait pas
été à la fois mise en lumière est
traitée et évidemment il ya des éléments
maintenant d' analyses qui sont des
éléments qui lie à la loi et on va
publier le 1er mars de nouveaux vous
donner un chiffre en exclusivité 2020 la
question de l'index quand vous savez une
femme qui est maintenant obligatoire
dans les entreprises et radio france
publié un index à 93 sur 100
cette année ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui sur toutes les fonctions
toutes les questions de rémunération sur
toutes les questions évidemment
d'évolution sur les questions
d'automatisation des promotions suite un
arrêt et une maternité sur toutes les
questions ne pars aussi dans les dix
meilleures rémunérations de l'entreprise
de la part des femmes toutes ces
questions maintenant font l'objet d'une
analyse évidemment statistiques qui sont
données au niveau des ressources
humaines et c'est des éléments
d'appréciation globale et je pense que
c'est un élément important parce qu'on
peu objective et aujourd'hui la question
de l'épanouissement et l'évolution
professionnelle au sein des entreprises
de médias publics comme privés mais
c'est valable pour toutes les
entreprises de france aujourd'hui donc
c'est un élément de mise en avant
deuxième élément c'est qu'effectivement
nous on a considéré que le contexte les
éléments le travail interne qui est fait
notamment sur la question la libération
de la parole toutes les campagnes que
nous mettons en place sur la cellule des
coups sur les sujets de harcèlement de
discrimination de parole sexistes ont
été mis en place de manière assez
précise on mobilise trois personnes dont
une représentant syndical pour qu'à tout
moment la capacité de saisir
la structure de sujets internes puisse
être mise en avant parce que c'est un
partant là en fait la structure et
maîtrise qu'on peut évidemment changer
la représentation et le discours cette
année mme en hyper important est
aujourd'hui qui fait l'objet d'une
attention particulière mandat du comité
diversité et avec un pilotage quasiment
hebdomadaire de ces sujets autre élément
que je vais vous donner aussi qui
concerne pour nous des sujets sur la
lutte contre le sexisme et les
représentations
nous lançons dès 2020 là dès le mois de
mars des conférence théâtralisée qui
vont mettre en scène des situations dans
l'ensemble des entités de radio france
au niveau managérial est également dans
toutes les stations locales et dans tous
les services
donc n'en sont pour que l'ensemble des
dirigeants et des services puissent
assister à une conférence interdisait
pour justement que la banalisation
d'appareils sexistes la banalisation de
la question de la discrimination soit
que soient comprises on sens delà de la
mise en scène et des groupes de paroles
donc c'est des éléments aussi hyper
important aussi bien dans la rédaction
et comme vous savez il ya des sujets qui
ont été qu'on ait émergé un moment donné
que dans les directions transverses ça
concerne l'ensemble des directions de
radio france qu'on considère que ce
sujet autour de autour de la
représentation et du sexisme n'est pas
un sujet uniquement rédactionnelle
évidemment c'est un sujet d'entreprise
tu as tous les niveaux et évidemment
pour l'épanouissement et troisième
élément je vous donnerai sont des
éléments d'appréciation si je pense pour
le législateur sur la question aussi de
la loi c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des dirigeants et cadres dirigeants qui
ont une l'objet d'une évaluation c'est à
dire près de 400 personnes ont
maintenant une question obligatoire sur
la question du respect de la charte il
est alité diversité et une évaluation
annuelle sur ce sujet est aujourd'hui
depuis 2020 ça va être mise en place et
c'est un élément extrêmement
d'appréciation dont je voulais souligner
dans cette première partie de mon
intervention je vais faire très courte
pour la seconde partie
vous allez voir que effectivement ce
sujet est un sujet interne et de manière
complémentaire pour les entreprises sur
les résultats qui sont les nôtres qui
sont importants évidemment on nous
sommes dans une logique de
deux sondages et d'évaluation de la
parole des femmes sur nos antennes
aujourd'hui deux mois par an nous nous
fondons l'ensemble des programmes est
actuellement sur 2010 9 43% des de la
parole à la radio france est une parole
féminine on est passé de 39 à 43% en un
an
donc ça c'est une vision quantitative ça
représente cependant deux fois à moi
100% de l' écoute de nos programmes au
delà ce qui a été précisé l'objectif et
50 pensent en 2022
ça a été annoncé par notre présidente et
évidemment on a un objectif de
progression évidemment de 5 à 10% par an
pour y arriver
c'est un élément c'est un élément
essentiel sûr je ne serais pas redondant
par rapport à ce que tu as dit sur la
question des expertes évidemment c'est
un sujet qu'on a pris à bras le corps
on ya dix sept rendez-vous qui sont
fondées et on a évidemment des moyens
humains pour le faire et on à 43%
d'experte en 2019 sur ces sujets il faut
encore progresser l'objectif est le même
que celui de france télévisions et la
question du guide des experts est
appréhendé ce qu'on continue un
financier mais la question c'est que ce
guide a besoin de plus de moyens et
notamment d'interventions peut-être du
secteur extérieur à radio france et
france télévisions et et les moyens que
mais ce sujet est également intégrée et
nous travaillons avec l'ina et je vais
en finir sur la question du contrôle pas
ce qu'avaient les questions sur le
contrôle juridique et nous considérons
qu'il ya deux types de contrôles
il ya la question interne qui veut dire
que le rôle de la médiatrice qui est
très important parce que le contrôle
s'est fait par les auditeurs et tout ce
qu'il dit à l'antenne et remonter les
médiatrices fait ce travail est
évidemment le rôle essentiel du csa sur
lesquels nous travaillons au jour le
jour et notamment sur la question
quantitative mais aussi qualitative
alors j'ai essayé d'être dans le temps
parti et je sais que quand on est à la
fin le temps merci monsieur
pour votre compréhension tout de suite
je vous passe la parole madame cheyrou
qui doit s'en aller dans grosse dizaine
de milles voilà merci madame la
présidente merci de nous avoir invité à
cette table ronde
pour ce qui est du groupe tf1 dont
groupe privé qui a été souvent cité en
tant que groupe privé qui ne pesait pas
forcément parfois grand chose je voulais
vous dire que tf1 déprogrammé une
politique ambitieuse en ce qui concerne
la représentation des femmes dans les
médias et cette politique a été mise en
oeuvre évidemment en interne mais aussi
avec des initiatives concernant nos
contenus sur l'information notamment la
fiction et le sport et je partagerai
donc mon temps de parole avec nathalie
genest ce nom qui reviendra sur les
chiffres du groupe de la fiction et du
sport et je vais vous présenter assez
rapidement ce que nous faisons en tout
cas au sein de l'information de tf1 avec
une direction qui a engagé une vraie
dynamique par rapport à cette
représentation des femmes dans les
médias
nous avons réalisé une étude en 2016 sur
le nombre de femmes qui étaient
présentes dans nos journaux télévisés
nous avons fait une étude sur 10 mais
nous avons compté parce qu'il faut
compter effectivement dans ont fait une
étude quantitative et qualitative avec
l'aide de brigitte grésy que vous
connaissez tous ici je pense sur les
critères critères évidemment pas que
quand tu y mets vraiment qualitatif et
nous avons évidemment traiter les jt du
week end du de la semaine du 13 heures
pour essayer d'améliorer évidemment nos
performances à l'issue de cette étude
nous avons mis en place un plan
pluriannuel pour mener des actions
différentes essayer de s'améliorer à
savoir nous avons créé des ateliers de
sensibilisation de tous les fabricants
de nos journaux les monteurs les
documentalistes mais aussi les
journalistes nous avons fait ces
ateliers avec l'aide de brigitte grésy
qui est venu nous accompagner pour
sensibiliser les journalistes aux
stéréotypes nous avons fait notre
autocritique nous avons réalisé des
critiques sur les sujets de nos de nos
jt nous avons également mis en place une
série de média training
grâce à des journées que nous appelons
les journées experte à la une au sein de
tf1 nous avons déjà réalisé deux
journées d'experte à la une il y en aura
une troisième en 2020 nous invitons des
expertes une centaine à chaque fois et
nous leur proposons des ateliers de
média training parce que comme le disait
christine kelly bien souvent les femmes
bien disputent aux deux fois non que oui
par rapport aux hommes pour intervenir à
la fois dans nos reportages mais aussi
sur nos plateaux de deux gîtes et donc
nous faisons du média training et nous
participons également avec l'association
vox femina à du média training sur les
lauréates puisqu'elle organise un
concours femmes ont vu tous les ans et
nous sommes partenaires depuis trois ans
avec vox féminin pour proposer du média
training individuel il y aura une
journée la semaine prochaine à ces
femmes qui ont été lauréate de ce
concours femmes en vue pour les aider
pour qu'elle puisse proposer aussi
quelque chose quand elles vont voir un
média parce que parfois on peut leur
demander s'ils sont déjà exprimé dans un
média etc
elles repartent avec une petite clé elle
requiert elles repartent avec leur petit
pitch et nous accompagnons pour qu'elles
se sentent plus à l'aise parce que la
difficulté c'est tout souvent celle ci
et nous utilisons également le guide qui
existent experte experte point eu mais
là aussi parfois les femmes qui sont
dans ce guide sont plutôt des
chercheuses des universitaires et nous
avons parfois aussi besoin de femmes qui
sont dans l'opérationnel pour répondre à
des questions dans nos reportages
télévisés qui s'adresse au plus grand
nombre évidemment nous avons également
mis en place un carnet notre propre
carnet d'adressés au sein des
différentes rédactions à la fois tf1 et
lci
puisque vous le savez il ya énormément
d'experte aussi qu'ils doivent venir sur
les plateaux de notre chaussure sur lci
donc nous partageons ce carnet nous
faisons évoluer au fil des ans parce que
nous savons que les journalistes parfois
ont des carnets qui sont toujours un peu
les mêmes et qui ont l'expert sur
l'économie qui vont toujours aller
chercher le même
donc nous les invitons à consulter et à
nourrir ce carnet d adresses qui
aujourd'hui c'est off et qui permet de
faire évoluer également nos chiffres
nous refaisons
une étude qui va être quantitative et
qualitative en 2020 nous en sommes là
nous en avons fait une en 2016 une en
2018 une en 2019 et nos chiffres je vais
finir avec avec des chiffres quand même
qu'ils sont qui sont plutôt qu'ils
s'améliorent et qui sont porteurs de
bons espoirs on va dire puisque sur
l'ensemble des femmes qui ont été
interrogés quand je dis l'ensemble des
femmes interrogées c'est dans nos
reportages télévisuels
nous étions à 33% je dirais en 2016 et
nous avons gagné près de 8 8 points sur
le dernier baromètre
alors évidemment on n'a pas encore
atteint cette parité mais ce sont les
objectifs et ce sont les objectifs fixés
par la direction de l'information pour
pour ça et sur les expertes
nous avons progressé quand même de 10
points et sur nos expertes tf1 qui sont
en plateau
nous avons progressé de 17 points et sur
les la représentation dans le en interne
au niveau de l'info nous avons un co
dire qui tu as et paritaire nous avons
des présentatrices qui sont des femmes
nous avons eu aussi une présentatrice
avant france télé qui était une femme au
20 heures quand même faut pas l'oublier
c'était laurence ferrari qui a présenté
le 20 heures durant quatre ans donc nous
sommes assez paritaire aussi au niveau
des rédacteurs en chef sur les
différentes émissions
moi je m'occupe principalement de 20
heures le mag et sachez que je m'efforce
d'être paritaire tous les soirs va en
tout cas sur l'année et d'avoir autant
de femmes que d'hommes
on est même un peu au dessus donc je
vais être discriminante un peu dans le
trou dans l'autre sens la semaine
prochaine nous faisons cinq portraits de
femmes sans forcément l'associer au 8
mars puisque nous sommes paritaire toute
l'année et c'est notre volonté au niveau
de la direction de la formation et nous
faisons preuve aussi de diversité parce
que j'entendais beaucoup parler de
diversité
et vous avez raison les femmes ne sont
pas juste des des wonder woman qui sont
soit des femmes politiques soient des
chefs d'entreprise se sont aussi des
femmes de tous les jours qu'il faut que
nous devons aussi allait voir les femmes
de l'ombre et donc nous sommes assez
paritaire aussi en ce qui concerne
toutes les diverses diversité aussi le
handicap femme de couleur parce que
c'est important aussi
donc voila nous essayons d'être d'être
un exemple en tout cas pour ce programme
là tous les soirs je vous invite à
regarder la semaine prochaine ce
programme voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire sur sur sur la sur l'info en
sachant que évidemment l'objectif c'est
du 50 50
comme france télévisions alors je serai
peut-être moins ambitieux de dire que ce
sera fin 2020 mais en tout cas c'est
l'objectif
et l'autre chose importante aussi dans
le plan d'action c'est que chaque chèque
dessus chaque chef de service à un
objectif de parité et qui joue aussi sur
sa part variable
donc ça c'est très important de le dire
parce que je pense qu'il ya peu
d'entreprises qui le font donc chaque
chef de service est en responsabilité
par rapport à ça voilà je laisse la
parole à nathalie lasselin pour la merci
à vous pour cette présentation est
forcément vous avez respecté le temps
puisque vous deviez nous quitter voilà
est-ce que ces chiffres la présentation
et lons où on peut aussi les recevoir
tout à fait je voulais juste faire un
petit enfin rajouté une chose c'est que
effectivement des effectivement madame
la présidente merci voilà on a on a fait
un petit zoom sur l'info parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya une attention particulière
est bien normal effectivement concernant
la représentation des femmes dans les
émissions d'information parce que
effectivement nous on a tous depuis
toujours intégré le rôle qui était le
nôtre à la fois de reflet de la société
mais aussi effectivement d'émergence
dans la conscience collective de
certaines choses impérative et donc ça
se cantonne pas forcément à
l'information parce que dans dans ma
dire dans dans dans l'esprit des gens il
ya à la fois cette représentation dans
les émissions d'informer la toule
d'autres pans comme france télévisions
le rappelait sur lesquels effectivement
on a fait un travail assez gigantesque
alors il ya des programmes
historiquement où on avait des héroïnes
et on a fait un énorme travail quand
même en terme de deux rôles qu'elle
occupe dans la société c'est dans la
fiction et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
va dire dans la fiction de tf1 qui est
quand même un des programmes majeurs de
des antennes on a essentiellement d or
et des héroïnes féminines qui ont des
postes de responsabilité et puis au delà
de ça en fait qu'ils sont souvent des
séries des séries que ce soit mon jeu
récemment ou alice nevers pour une
fiction plus ancienne mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'est aussi attaqué à parce que la
société véritablement comment dire très
sensibles à ces sujets d'abord ça a été
les actions qu'on a menées autour de
violences faites aux femmes c'est à dire
que le jour on a mis l'emprise
acquittent une une fiction très violente
l'emprise à l'antenne ça fait un certain
moment c'était une prise de risque
majeur ça a secoué les mentalités ce
c'était tout le processus qui conduit
effectivement à voilà au quotidien d'une
femme battue comment elle rentre dans
cette spirale et comment elle peut
arriver à son effet ça lui a
effectivement un écho retentissant
on est allé toujours dans ceux de enfin
on a continué aussi parce qu'on a eu la
sphère jacqueline sauvage qui nous a
tous secoués
on l'a adaptée ça a été un énorme succès
d'audience mais c'est comment dire c'est
nécessaire aussi d'interpeller pas
seulement en fait via des émissions
d'information mais aussi quelque part
dans des émissions qui ont une portée
enfin des petits pots logis de
programmes qui ont une portée très
importante et je rejoins ce que disait
dans la même continuité on avait un
succès majeur sur le bazar de la charité
qui est quand même qui a pour sujet
l'émancipation de trois femmes suite
suite à cette à cette catastrophe
pareille un succès retentissant dont il
ya une vraie appétence sur les destins
de femmes et sur des femmes en
commentaires sur les femmes puissantes
on recense à cette attente de nos
téléspectateurs il en va de même et
outre le fait que ça joue sur la
formation en fait d esprit on sait que
notre public jeune aujourd'hui et en
appétence sur des rôles féminins
important on a mis à l'antenne
un petit personnage qui s'appelle lydie
bug depuis plusieurs années qui est un
carton monumental est dans la lignée bon
on sait qu'il ya aussi une action à
mener sur le plus jeune public
d'ailleurs france télévisions la palapa
cité mais c'était en cofinançant ce
moment avec disney france télévisions et
m6 un petit module autour des
stéréotypes qui sera un petit module
l'animation qui sera adressé aux au plus
haut plus jeune public alors aussi un
énorme un énorme comment dire les normes
tendance qu'on a constatée dans les
dents les les année dernière c'est
l'émergence du sport féminin le sport
féminin sur les antennes ya encore cinq
ans sur des antennes en clair on se
posait la question de de la pertinence
on a fait ce pari dès 2015 on a on a été
acquéreur des droits on a accompagné
l'équipe de france de football ont fait
la même chose sur l'équipe de france de
handball et puis on est à fond il ya eu
l'euro l'euro de l'équipe de france mais
on est oui qui a beaucoup j'avais le
site et on a on a fait tout ce travail
de réflexion avec le csa autour du sport
féminin
on a vu comment les choses avançaient
aujourd'hui la question est plus sur les
organes dirigeants des fédérations que
l'exposition puisque je vous avais une
quelque chose ça a été aussi une
surprise pour nous on pensait que l'euro
la coupe du monde féminine serait un
grand succès mais se dire qu'on atteint
les mêmes niveaux potentiellement par en
finale ne s'ouvre pas qualifié mais les
mêmes niveaux que l'équipe de france
masculine
nous nous étions ravis car nous sommes
une chaîne privée commerciale il faut
quand même financé par la publicité mais
ça dit beaucoup de la société cela dit
énormément de la société donc voilà ça
c'est le fruit aussi et je rejoins ce
que disait france télévisions c'est
c'est aussi le fruit quelque part aussi
d'un mouvement dans notre entreprise
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui nous sommes
56 % de salariés et dans l'entreprise tf
dans les différents comités de direction
les choses ont évolué aussi
substantiellement
on a ce qu'on appelle un comité
management au sein de tf1 qui regroupe
les principaux managers
aujourd'hui on n'a pas atteint la parité
mais on est quand même à 40 % on a fait
des progrès assez assez assez important
et tout ça c'est le fruit aussi d'un
travail très important qui a consisté à
accompagner les femmes dans l'entreprise
il ya des programmes spéciaux qui ont
été mis en oeuvre de manteaux ring de
session spéciale pour accompagner les
managers je n'aime pas trop le terme
mais dans leur progression pour éviter
effectivement que ce plafond de verre
persiste parce qu'elles ne se sentent
pas crédibles dans leurs preuves dans
l'or dans leurs commandes hier
progression professionnelle alors ça a
apporté des résultats très positifs
on est on a atteint alors pas peut-être
pas 93% mais 85% par dont 85 points sur
100 dans la cotation au niveau des
entreprises qui qui respecte l'égalité
professionnelle donc voilà les progrès
sont visibles ils sont importants on a
tort de croire que les engagements qu'on
prend auprès du csa sont limitées on
vient de signer des nouvelles
conventions sur lesquels en matière
d'info on s'est engagé à aller vers la
parité on s'est engagés même à le faire
sur la représentation des femmes
politiques dans le temps de parole chose
qui n'est pas forcément aisé toujours
parce qu'on n'est pas seul
il ya aussi la représentation dans les
différents partis mais voilà on fait un
travail main dans la main avec le cs en
la matière il ya le travail dans
l'entreprise
le travail des antennes qui se fait avec
le csa sur lequel très honnêtement on a
pu on a pu voir des incitations qui ont
porté leurs fruits réellement d'abord je
voudrais remarquer et féliciter
effectivement toutes les chaînes qui ont
fait des efforts j'ai présidé au début
de ses efforts ou csa à propos de la
délibération fin de la loi de 2014 que
permis la délibération de 2015
qui a couché quand même dans la douleur
il faut se le rappeler parce que c'était
très nouveau pour les chaînes d'avoir
des nouvelles obligations c'était
difficile nous avons eu 18 réunion de
mise au point de discussion pour voir
comment nous allons fonctionner et les
choses se sont mises en place avec ses
rapports annuels qui sont très très
importants et il y a eu aussi la
possibilité de sanctions elles ont eu
lieu sur des dérapages des propos des
images dégradantes et avec l'aval du
conseil d'état quand et où des recours
donc il ya eu en quelques années un
énorme progrès de fait ceci dit il reste
à faire les quelques constats canton
compte de progrès doivent pas cacher les
problèmes qui restent globalement il y a
que 42 % de femmes contre 58 sur les
antennes la proportion de femmes et 39 %
entre 18h et 20h elle tombe à 29% entre
21h et 23h donc nous aurons de grandes
écoutes chez les
les expertes sont 37% en moyenne et
c'est andy moyenne quand on sait que le
service public et tous dessus ça veut
dire que il ya des chaînes à la traîne
je vais pas citer les mauvais élèves
mais y en a
le temps de parole est effectivement que
d'un tiers alors que la présence des
femmes est de 42% d'entre elles sont là
quand elles sont 42% et non que 37%
plutôt parole donc il y a encore du
boulot à faire pour parler simplement et
au conseil à l'égalité nous avons
réfléchi à la manière dont on pourrait
encore améliorer les choses sur le plan
législatif puisque il y à l'occasion qui
nous est donné avec le projet de
l'audiovisuel ne peut être complété les
dispositions actuelles et d'en créer des
nouvelles parce qu'il n'ya pas que le
secteur et retient il ya le secteur
numérique qui est autrement grave parce
qu'effectivement dans le secteur
audiovisuel et des progrès mais il reste
des trous dans la raquette et dans le
secteur numérique et rien donc sur le le
plan législatif pour essayer de
renforcer le dispositif
nous avons proposé au hce à partir de la
photographie que font les chaînes de
radio télévision chaque année de
demander qu'il y ait un progrès il
suffit pas juste le s'évaluer mais qui
est un progrès si minime soit-il
annuellement
c'est pas le cas de toutes les chaînes
et surtout ce n'est pas le cas pour
toutes les tranches horaires dans toutes
les émissions et dans tous les genres
parce qu'il faut aussi faire un peu de
qualitatif il suffit pas d'avoir une
moyenne de femmes qui passent à 4 heures
de l'après midi ou en fin de soirée et
qui parle que du caire il faut aussi que
les femmes parlent de tout et des rôles
de sachants important là aussi ce serait
intéressant de voir sur les experts
invités de quel sujet on leur demande de
parler juste le nom experte mais les
sujets concernés
donc il faut je pense resserré un tout
petit peu les mailles du filet et
demande et surtout qui est la
constatation annuellement d'un progrès
parce que la plupart effectivement des
chênes enfin beaucoup d'échelle
importantes s'engage sur le 50 50 mais
on n'y est pas ça va être difficile et
celles qui en sont loin
il faut vraiment qui est un progrès
voilà c'est une idée pour vos travaux
nous allons insister j'en ai parlé aussi
à vos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
c'est en tout cas la position du hc
deuxième énorme problème parce que là le
champ et vierge c'est le numérique nous
avons a réussi par exemple sur
l'audiovisuel
il ya aussi non seulement compter mais
regarder quels types d'imagés à l'écran
il y a encore quelques problèmes
j'en ai discuté avec szczesny ci
présente les programmes de télé-réalité
miss france ce genre de programme très
stéréotypé c'est que les chaînes ont
conscience qu'elle essaie de faire des
efforts mais il ya tout de même pour des
déchaîne sur le hertzien quelques
problèmes à corriger et j'espère que si
on demande de faire un progrès c'est
aussi en comptant l'évaluation des
stéréotypes des émissions et donc il ya
un peu moins
ce type d'émission là sur le numérique
il ya l'occasion dans le projet de loi
audiovisuel de la transposition de la
directive et ses mains cette directive
de le pouvoir aux régulateurs européens
d'intervenir si des propos haineux ou
préjudiciable à la jeunesse sont
diffusées je pense que et c'est dommage
que ça pète et mis tout de suite mais un
pays peut toujours rajouter on peut
rajoutez un sujet qui les cultes qui
serait souhaitable que soit rajouté
comme mission de régulateur d'aussi de
faire éliminer les images aux propos
dégradants pour les femmes
il suffit pas de mettre les propos
haineux mes images dégradantes et propos
dégradants et on a tellement sur
internet que au moins d'être un peu
menacé d'avoir une sanction
ça fera peut-être que les gaffes à
nettoieront un peu plus ces séquences là
parce que vraiment on a par exemple fait
c'était mes derniers travaux c'est ça
fait une étude sur le secteur numérique
soit l'année 2017 et 2018 sur les 2 100
séquences les plus vues sur youtube
les 100 plus vu en 2017 comme en 2018
était aux trois quarts des clips
musicaux en analysant ses clips musicaux
français
on s'est rendu compte du désastre
la plupart chez les hommes qui ont le
rôle principal les femmes sont là en
rôles secondaires ou en garniture et
elles sont traités de tous les noms et
dans des postures dégradantes et cette
création est financé par le cnc donc
nous sommes assez tenté de demander les
gars conditionnalité vous savez qu'on
réserve le financement public
les aides publiques à des productions
toute activité qui respecte l'image des
femmes et je veux dire que j'espère que
ça retiendra votre attention parce que
si vous regardez ses clips musicaux vous
verrez que vraiment est quelque chose
qui va pas donc nous avons imaginé un
amendement pour la directive et ses
mains
je peux pas vous donner le détail
technique mais on peut peut-être parler
après pour prévoir donc l'ajout de
l'image des femmes
nous souhaiterions également dans la
dernière ligne droite
la proposition de loi
laetitia 1 via rajoute également l'image
et les propos dégradants pour les femmes
non ce qu'il doit être retiré oui oui
non meilleur et un dernier petit passage
à l'assemblée si vous mettiez d'accord
dans un dernier élan tous les
parlementaires pour ajouter cet aspect
parce que pour l'instant comme vous
savez cette loi faire sanctionner que
des manquements manifestes à la loi et
ce qui serait l'idéal évidemment c'est
que la loi prévoit qu'on n'ait pas le
droit de diffuser et de prononcer des
images et des propos dégradants pour les
femmes
pour l'instant c'est ça concerne
simplement l'audiovisuel ça ne concerne
pas le numérique et ça ne concerne pas
non plus des personnes détentrices
d'autorité ou dans les lieux publics est
encore énormément de propos d'une image
dégradante qui sont partout diffusé sans
sanction du tout enfin je m'en tiendrais
pour aujourd'hui ce qui est possible
dans la loi audiovisuelle
donc si vous deviez retenir deux idées
progression annuelle a constaté pour les
chaînes de radio de télévision et si
possible sur des critères un peu plus
resserrée pour ne pas qu'il y ait trop
de trous dans le filet ou qu'ils soient
trop gros et puis disposition pour la
directive et ses mains on complète pour
l'image des propos des perdants pour les
femmes
j'irai pas plus loin parce que vous
connaissez nos positions et je vous
remercie beaucoup de m'avoir aussi merci
madame la présidente je vais passer la
parole à deux des collègues qui ont
demandé donc maryvonne blondin est
ensuite marc laure darcos par non et
donc je vous laisserai répondre à ces
questions les personnes qui souhaiteront
répondre dans toutes les personnes qu'on
a entendu ce matin le ferons merci
madame la présidente
merci à chacune et chacun d'entre vous
pour cette présentation fort
intéressante qui fait l'état des lieux
actuel de la place des femmes dans l'est
dans les médias et moi je ne pouvais
m'empêcher de penser à 2014 2014 j'étais
rapporteur pour avis de la délégation
aux droits des femmes et pour cette loi
sur l'égalité réelle entre les femmes et
les hommes est donc là nous avons
beaucoup travaillé modifier un article 3
en rajoutant rallye n'est à la juste
représentation des femmes et des hommes
dans les programmes de services de
communication etc à l'image là et puis
un article 20 21 1 qui précise
véritablement lit le rôle que devait
avoir le csa est confiée tout ça au csa
qui ensuite a fait le travail pas facile
disiez vous madame pierre brossolette
mais ô combien est nécessaire et
d'ailleurs vous avez rendu compte devant
les les commissions les commissions de
l'époque donc je constate
pendant ces six ans parce que dans une
semaine qu'il y a eu quelques quelques
progrès néanmoins essayé et c'est très
bien j'aurais voulu moi vous demandez
pas ce qu'il faut que j'arrive très vite
également lorsque vous évoquiez tout le
travail d'accompagnement de ces des
femmes pour les aider à franchir et et a
crevé ce plafond de verre
dans le la dans la rh vous avez pris en
compte parce que ce qu'on constate s
étaient les difficultés des femmes
lorsqu'elles étaient enceintes où tu
sais qu'elle était l'accueil moi
j'aurais voulu qu'on ait une précision
sur justement l'accompagnement des
femmes qui attendent un bébé et le
retour après le congé de maternité voir
comment vous mettez tout cela en place
est évoqué nous avons parlé des
réalisatrices surtout de fiction est-ce
que je pense que vous avez des
réalisatrices dans d'autres émissions et
notamment les émissions sportives de
femmes bien sûr danser dans vos
programmes
et moi je quand vous avez évoqué les
figures de l'ombre et quand vous avez
dit qu'elle était comme au combien
importante jeu je réagissais à
l'actualité
il y à une mathématicienne de la nasa
âgé de 102 ans qui vient de décéder et
vraiment on ne connaissait pas moi je
je ne la connaissais pas et je suis allé
regarder il y en a énormément
en plus elle était noire donc déjà il y
avait des choses moi j'aurais souhaité
trouver quelque part sur les
informations les les chaînes de
télévision peut être un reportage précis
là-dessus
elle s'appelle je croyais s'appelle
catherine johnson
elle s'appelait catherine johnson il y
en a eu et on a eu bon ben j'ai pas bien
j'ai pas bien vu la publication de tout
ça et puis quand vous parliez du
stéréotype et tous vous avez vu à
qu'actuellement qu'il y a une
miss allemagne qui vient d'être élu à la
35 ans elle a un bébé voilà elle ne se
présente pas en maillot de bain c'est un
nouveau concours allemand qui vient
d'être lancé c'est juste pour évoquer
cela mais en tout cas sachez qu'on va
regarder toujours cette progression
régulière annuel telle que vous la l'a
demandé et surtout ne baissez pas les
bras et continuez vos efforts merci
merci chers collègues j'ai tout de suite
passé la parole à laure darcos sachez qu
on aura également des travaux qui vont
être menés nous entendrons le csa bien
entendu et les institutionnels
laure darcos d'autres collègues oui je
vais très courte aussi juste des petits
clins d'oeil
je ne sais pas maintenant quels seront
les critères de dymat mais pendant des
années ça a été la ménagère de plus de
50 ont donc déjà ménagères plus de 50
ans tout ça m'était insupportable mais
maintenant c'est la femme responsable
des achats
ah c'est toujours la femme et la femme
responsable et à ça on a changé donc
déjà ces normes fin je trouve que comme
changement et puis c'est vrai que
peut-être qu'elle regarde que cette
révision mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
comme je les ai souvent dit à des
responsables de chaînes jeu
je prends toujours l'exemple de mon fils
de 19 ans plus aucun jeune ne regardent
la télévision etc autant vrai pour les
jeunes filles que pour les jeunes hommes
et donc je pense que en termes de
numérique il faut penser en effet aux
deux aux deux genres et notamment je
pense qu'il faudrait mettre à l'honneur
c'est le côté rapporteur du budget de la
recherche tout ce qui est métiers
scientifiques et numérique
et c'est vrai qu'on met pas sa l'honneur
ces femmes là j'étais content de voir
quand même marina carrère d'encausse
répondent à des questions sur le coroner
virus ces derniers ces derniers jours
sinon mettait plutôt à l'honneur des
chefs de service hommes alors qu'ils
sont au demeurant sont très brillants
notamment à cette pétri hier mais je
pense que par le biais du numérique on
peut amener à avoir des messages
positifs sur la revalorisation de ces
métiers qui malheureusement et c'est
navrant baisse par rapport à il ya 20
ans en fait on n'a plus que 15 % de
femmes qui se dirige vers des mets des
métiers scientifiques
je ferai un petit qu'un petit petit
différence ce cher sévit entre la télé
réalité à une émission comme miss france
moi j'avais été choquée
pour rien de caché de cette polémique
sur miss france quand on voit le nombre
encore de téléspectateurs bon bien
évidemment on peut peut-être les faire
parler autrement les valoriser autrement
peut-être sur leur d'ailleurs leur
activité professionnelle ou leurs études
souvent elles font des études à ses
brillantes mais mais ça reste encore je
trouve à 1 plutôt valorisant pour pour
nos régions parce qu'on parle encore de
nos régions où nos pays et donc moi je
crois une différence par contre en télé
réalité je trouve que les images sons
sont dégradantes
comme je ne sais pas pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à changer ça quand on fait
une occurrence sur google d'une
célébrité femmes
la première occurrence qui passe c'est
nu voilà systématiquement vous regardez
une chanteuse une actrice vous mettez
son nom la première occurrence est nu
voilà donc ça veut dire que les gens
choisis et 20 les hommes particuliers
vont commencer par essayer de trouver
des photos d'elle nue ou en tout cas
dans des dans des tenues sûrement
chatoyantes
ce n'est pas le cas pour les hommes et
je trouve que de la même façon pas
encore réussi à gérer ce genre de
problème d'occurrence com
tu l'as dit les problèmes d'accès à des
des sites ou pornographique ou en tout
cas dégradante pour la femme
donc voilà et sinon je n'avais rien
d'autre à dire de particulier mais
simplement jeu je trouve compliqué
peut-être mon avis mais dans la mode au
visuel sera moins con tu puisses
nous-mêmes de même toi même nous définir
les critères pour resserrer les critères
de 2,2 de changement enfin voilà enfin
de deux mètres de mise en avant de la
féminité dans l'est dans les programmes
ou dans les émissions mais on est à ta
disposition mais évidemment pour cette
loi audiovisuelle merci chers collègues
je vais juste non le tour s'il vous
plaît sylvie pierre brossolette
parce que sinon on va pas s'en sortir
mais juste pour répondre peut-être et je
me permets moi la meilleure promotion
des territoires
c'est quand même le tour de france alors
voilà et donc je vais juste passé si
vous le permettez sylvie la parole à
notre collègue victoire j'espère et
après vous aurez tout le loisir de vous
exprimer mais dame
oui merci merci beaucoup même la
présidence et merci à vous tous
parce que c'était très enrichissant je
voudrais poser une question à monsieur
du camp d'en savoir dont il a fait
l'analyse des données sur les
différentes chaînes
je souhaiterais savoir monsieur si vous
avez également travaillé sur les chaînes
première qui concerne les autres maires
est ce que vous avez fait l'analyse des
données concernant les chaînes première
et l'autre d'autres choses nous avons
ici même au sein de la délégation
travailler sur un rapport concernant le
football féminin
mais le sport en général et nous avons
eu évidemment à auditionner les
journalistes sportifs et parmi lesquels
une femme qui était la seule femme
évidemment le jour de l'audition il ya
elle nous a bien dit qu'elle n'était pas
n hésitez pas nombreuses à être des
journalistes sportives et nous avons
vraiment apprécié cette audition parce
qu'elle nous a également
prouver que les femmes avaient toute
leur place dans le sport et en tant que
journaliste est la dernière chose
j'apprécie beaucoup les interventions
concernant les clips parce que sur nos
territoires
il ya de plus en plus les bouquets qui
sont proposés des avec un certain nombre
de chaînes et de plus en plus et la
cyphose l'intérêt des données l'analyse
des données serait intéressante parce
que il ya beaucoup de chaînes qui
propose des clips et là évidemment les
images des femmes ne sont pas forcément
valoriser et la dernière chose le sénat
a organisé lors la délégation aux
premières avec le sénat évidemment un
rapport aussi les risques naturels
majeurs je trouve malheureusement que
sur l'ensemble des chaînes
il n'y a pas une mise en valeur du
travail du sénat notamment pour les
différents rapports concernant la
prévention c'est valable dans là pour
les risques naturels majeurs j'étais co
rapporteurs mais sur d'autres sujets qui
sont importants pour vous parler d'
expertise c'est vrai qu'il ya les femmes
expertes mais jouer souhaitait vraiment
que vous puissiez également faire de la
pédagogie dans bien des domaines
pour l'ensemble du territoire quels que
soient les niveaux et quelle que soit la
chaîne et là je crois que ça manque
énormément heureusement que nous avons
public sénat c'est vrai mais il faudrait
qu'il y ait la possibilité que les
autres chaînes puissent faire un travail
de relais et éventuellement non je ne
sais pas comment les conventions ce
fonds
je ne vais pas entrer dans ce schéma là
mais il ya un travail qui se fait nous
représentons les territoires il y à une
représentation de l'ensemble du
territoire national et je crois que il
ya de grandes inégalités de grandes
disparités dans la façon d'appréhender
les différentes problématiques donc je
souhaiterais vraiment que le travail du
sénat soient valorisés à travers vos
différentes chine
je vous remercie merci à nos trois
collègues donc je vais vous laisser
répondait voilà chers sylvie madame la
présidente c'est à vous juste pour
répondre alors sur la possibilité de
faire progresser et avec un peu plus de
précisions les chiffres donnés par les
chaînes on pourrait prendre déjà comme
critère
les tranches horaires que les femmes ne
disparaissent pas aux tranches horaires
on pourra commencer par ça et après
vérifie les rôles qu'elles ont mais je
demande des moyens mais je pense qu'il
faudrait faire en réalité une étude tous
les trois ans financé par l'état de
présenter devant le parlement
très qualitative et qui permettent de
dire très précisément de quoi les femmes
parlent à quel moment faire des choses
qui seront peut-être un peu lourde pour
les chaînes à réaliser donc c'est ce
tour était une grande étude qui
éclairait la représentation nationale
sur qu'est ce qui se passe exactement
parce qu'on sait c'est vrai qu'il faut
se mettre 24 heures sur 24 devant une
écran accepte est un peu lourd mais déjà
les horaires et les types d'émissions on
peut faire progresser
et quant à miss france je l'aimé pas
dans le même sac évidemment la
téléréalité miss france on en a parlé
ensemble
il ya déjà des progrès de fait sur miss
france ça reste une émission qui est
quand même controversé je sais les
féministes trouve que c'est à chaque
fois pas l'heure où il ya tous les goûts
sont dans la nature jerlaure mais c'est
un problème qu'on peut évoquer tous
merci de votre
thomert ci alors je vais passer est-ce
que non mais juste juste un petit clin
d'oeil c'est que dans l'est peut-être
dans les critères on pourrait comme
daddy victoire m une des critères sur
est-ce qu'on peut prendre aussi de temps
en temps des sénatrices plutôt que des
députés et que le sénat soit plus
représenté dans les émissions de
télévision émission politique ça serait
très juste et je te remercie victoire de
l'avoir dit 6 merci de deux ans on va
essayer de poursuivre de manière
synthétique quand même jusqu'à la fin
parce que moi aussi je fais partie de la
commission culture donc je il y en a
d'autres membres ce matin donc ça aurait
été quand même bien qu'on puisse y
accéder à un moment donné je vais comme
monsieur a été david doukhan du grand
pardon a été directement interpellé par
la sénatrice de guadeloupe
est-ce que vous avez les éléments de
réponse où vous ne les enverrait
peut-être monsieur très bien donc
sur l'analyse des chaînes outre-mer on
analyse et france ô
je ne sais pas si ça compte alors
l'autre l'autre chose on a analysé les
j'étais à genoux il y avait la corse
non blaya bon blague à part la haye ap
blague à part je je sais même pas si ces
chaînes sont captés par l'ina en 27 sur
24 et saluer
ça peut vous voir vous consoler ou pas
philippe était pas capté jusqu'en
novembre 2019 et pour chaque nouvelle
captation faut souvent faire des actions
de lobbying en interne
donc je vous invite à nous transmettre
la liste des chaînes que vous
souhaiteriez capter et on peut voir ce
qu'on peut faire
alors cette réponse c'est quand même
assez intéressante puisque on à un
moment donné dit qu'il fallait compter
les femmes pour que les femmes compte je
ne sais plus qui sait vous madame qui
avait dit ça donc chers victoire jasmin
il ya du travail pour les territoires
autres
d'autres maires oui madame nathalie la
non mais je voulais juste répondre à une
question qui était posée sur sur
l'accompagnement parce que ce qui est
fait en interne en fait sur
l'accompagnement des femmes enceintes
c'est vrai que alors ça c'est un fait
et ça vient beaucoup aussi à un moment
historiquement d'un manager peut-être
masculin qui consiste à dire puisque ma
collaboratrice par an de congé maternité
elle va pas être augmentés et puisque ma
collaboratrice rentrer de congé
maternité elle ne sera pas augmenté
alors ça c'est quelque chose sur lequel
on s'est attaqué depuis longtemps
effectivement on a un principe d'abord
compter les collaboratrices pendant en
tout cas leur maternité il ya un
accompagnement ça c'est plus si j'ose
dire d'ordre médical mais de 2
enfin de faire quelques bénéficient de
journée où elles peuvent travailler chez
elle au journal où elle se repose enfin
en fonction de l'avancement de de la
grossesse après l oms au retour de leur
congé maternité à un entretien avec la
drh et nous surtout on a un système qui
consiste à dire si une collaboratrice
n'est pas augmentée si on constate qu'il
n'y a pas eu d'augmentation qui est
souvent le signal en départ en congé
maternité qu'on aille il en fait toute
progression parce que justement il s'est
passé ça et bien une augmentation
automatique de plein droit de 2% qui qui
en fait permis de pallier à ce système
là après si elle est augmenté parce
qu'elle a une management à la management
féminin qui connaît ce genre de problème
mais ça voilà à mon avis c'est plus la
féminisation du management fait aussi
que à un moment on a vécu ça je laisse
la parole à christine kelly qui
souhaitait répondre également oui merci
madame la présidente 3,3 points le
premier point sur l'autre mère pour dire
que l'autre mère est définitivement
entièrement à part on le constate
on le constate même dans la réponse ce
que je regrette et je partage à la fois
des clips est à la fois votre constat et
j'ai beaucoup alerté lorsque j'étais au
csa france télévisions en disant que les
clips notamment en outre mer sont
absolument désastreux pour l'image de la
femme
ce dont faisait aussi du pire
brossolette c'est en métropole mer notre
mère s'est multipliée par dix c'est
humiliant deuxième point pour vous dire
que je vais vous transmettre une note
écrite sur les avancées du groupe canal+
je ne suis pas venu avec les chiffres du
groupe canal+ avec ses news c8 canal+ ce
qui est fait en matière de sur ces
sujets là et le troisième point pour
dire que je suis très adepte du
convaincre plutôt que contraindre et ça
a toujours été mon leitmotiv lorsque
j'étais au csa par exemple lorsque j'ai
créé cette journée pour le sport féminin
de visibilité sur le sport féminin où on
a vraiment fait un pas en avant
exceptionnels sur le sport féminin
il n'y avait aucune contrainte
uniquement de la conviction uniquement
de la discussion
uniquement des avances et uniquement
qu'est ce que chacun peut faire pour
avancer ensemble et je crois beaucoup
à cet esprit où on peut faire évoluer
les choses bien sûr il faut la
contrainte mais aussi convaincre on va
parfois plus vite plus loin plus fort
avec plus de résultats s est ce qu'il y
à d'autres ah oui tiens oui on a parlé
tout à l'heure de pardon madame la
présidente je réponds rapidement mais en
a parlé tout à l'heure de visibilité de
femmes dans des journalistes sportifs y
en a de plus on a de plus en plus sain
il y en a de plus en plus ya une
véritable progression
ça ne suffit pas mais y en a deux en
plus des réalisatrices ça il y en a pas
suffisamment c'est clair mais à tout
point de vue c'est sûr qu'il ya des
avancées mais comme on l'a tous dit
autour de la table les avancées toujours
insuffisante
c'était la table ronde sur la place des
femmes dans les médias audiovisuels
une table ronde organisée par la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat l'occasion de saluer la présence
des femmes à la tête des entreprises
audiovisuelles françaises
les femmes sont également visibles sur
les plateaux mais elles ont beaucoup
moins la parole que les hommes
des progrès restent à faire et ce sera
tout l'enjeu de la réforme de
l'audiovisuel public qui sera examiné au
sénat
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez revoir tous
nos programmes sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
public sénat